[موسيقى]
اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من الجليل الاعلى
اهلا بكم ارتفاع عدد الشهداء الفلسطينيين
الى نحو
4400 وسط تحذيرات من تحول المستشفيات الى
مقابر جماعيه بسبب نقص الادويه والوقود في
حين دخلت اليوم اول قافله للمساعدات
من معبر رفح وقالت الحكومه في غزه ان
القافله التي تضم 20 شاحنه لن تغير
الكارثه الانسانيه وطالبت بفتح المعبر
بشكل دائم كتائب القسام تطلق سراح محتجزين
امريكيتين لدواع انسانيه واستجابه لجهود
قطريه الرئيس الامريكي الشكر قطر على
مسعاها بينما قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
القطريه ان الح حوار سيستمر مع اسرائيل
وحماس للافراج عن الرهائن المدنيين من كل
الجنسيات مع انطلاق قمه للسلام في القاهره
الرئيس المصري يجدد رفضه التهجير القصري
للفلسطينيين ويعتبره تصفيه نهائيه لقضيتهم
والعاهل الاردني يصف استهداف المدنيين في
غزه بجريمه حرب في حين اكد الرئيس
الفلسطيني ان دوامه العنف تتجدد كل فتره
بسبب غياب العداله واهمال حقوق
الفلسطينيين استمرار التوتر والقصف
المتبادل على الحدود الشماليه مع لبنان
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي تفقد قواته هناك
وقال ان حزب الله قرر المشاركه في الحرب
وتوعده بدفع ثمن باهظ ورئيس المجلس
التنفيذي في حزب الله يقول ان الحزب سيكون
حاضرا في كل الجبهات
بصواريخ
وسلاحه الى
اللقاء